monique décollage réussi pour le lanceur
ariane 5 depuis kourou cet après-midi la
fusée emporte avec elle le deuxième
satellite de renseignement
helios coût du programme 2 milliards
d'euros à quoi ça sert ce reportage
exclusif pierre babey rick genest et
stéphane corbin ont obtenu
l'autorisation exceptionnelle de
pénétrer dans les locaux de la dgse la
célèbre mais secrète piscine à 700 km de
la terre dans l'oeil d'hélios garacad la
côte somalienne ses repaires de pirates
ces bateaux ses équipages prise en otage
on peut voir ici et une embarcation de
petite taille qui peut correspondre à
l'embarcation servant soit au pire à
tous aux négociateurs et lyng et la
frontière soudanaise ces camps de
réfugiés ces groupes terroristes sa
misère qu'ils mangent inexorablement le
paysage ici en 2004
y a rien en 2009 une signature bien
particulière ces camps de déplacés qui
correspondent à des tentes des bâches
lyon guillaume le principal site
nucléaire nord-coréen ses installations
et surtout les aléas de sa politique
entre prolifération et au raid programme
une image prix donc dans la nuit du 2 au
3 novembre 2009 nous permet de constater
que plus aucun signal n'était eni dans
cette partie du site est donc le
réacteur n'était plus dans l'activité
les crises
vu du ciel ou plutôt de l'espace leur
image intériste ici à la dgse sur les
écrans et dans les yeux des
interprétateurs les satellites ont la
capacité de pouvoir tourner autour de la
terre de pouvoir prendre des prises de
vue de la terre sans contrainte
juridique particulière en clair sans
demander à quiconque le droit de
survoler son territoire tout à fait les
sales d'interprétation images ce sont
les locaux les plus discrets les mieux
gardés du siège de la dgse
car les dossiers d'actualité contre est
ici sont parmi les plus brûlants de
grands thèmes majeurs
le premier c'est la lutte contre le
terrorisme le second la lutte contre la
prolifération
oui
oui prolifération travaux pratiques
l'imagerie infrarouge les taches rouges
égal de la chaleur égal de l'activité
plus de tâches égale arrêt certains des
installations la végétation même en
témoigne cette image date donc de la
nuit du 2 au 3 novembre nous permet en
comparaison d'autres images nous permet
de confirmer qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'évolution au niveau de la végétation
au sein du site de lyon vient la
précision des photos secret défense mais
moins d'un mètre
suffisant en tout cas pour avoir à
l'oeil n'importe quel point chaud de la
planète en 100 photos par jour et en
toute indépendance